>>> SO.
SO IT HAPPENED TO YOU.
>> YOUR WORST NIGHTMARE.
>> WE'VE ALL BEEN THERE.
YOU RAN OUT OF HAIR PRODUCT AND
YOU USED GORILLA GLUE INSTEAD.
>> AND IT TURNED YOUR BEAUTIFUL,
LUSCIOUS MANE INTO A HARD CANDY
SHELL.
>> HI, I'M DENZEL COMMODE.
>> AND I'M LATRICE COMMODE.
AND IF THIS HAS HAPPENED TO YOU,
YOU ARE NOT ALONE AND THIS IS
NOT YOUR FAULT.
>> AND YOU ARE NOT DUMB.
>> FACT.
EVERY DAY AS MANY AS ONE PEOPLE
FALL VICTIM TO USING GORILLA
GLUE IN PLACE OF A BEAUTY
PRODUCT AND THEY DESERVE
COMPENSATION.
>> WE ALL DO.
YOU SHOULD NOT HAVE TO GO
THROUGH LIFE WITH HAIR LIKE A
LEGO MAN BECAUSE ONE TIME YOU
USED GORILLA GLUE INSTEAD OF
WAVE GREASE.
>> WE WILL GET YOU MONIES FROM
GORILLA GLUE OR THE NEXT BEST
THING.
>> A LIFETIME SUPPLY OF GORILLA
GLUE.
BUT DON'T JUST TAKE OUR WORD FOR
IT.
>> MY NAME IS CHANTEL.
I RAN OUT OF LEAVE-IN
CONDITIONER SO I REACHED FOR THE
NEXT BEST THING, GORILLA GLUE.
SEEMS HARMLESS, RIGHT?
WELL, IT WAS NOT.
AND BEFORE YOU JOKERS ON THE
INTERNET SAY I SHOULD HAVE READ
THE DAMN LABEL, I DID.
IT JUST SAYS, REALLY STRONG
GLUE, AND DANGEROUS.
THAT CAN MEAN ANYTHING, GORILLA
GLUE.
YOU GOTS TO PAY!
>> AND THEY WILL.
OR MY NAME ISN'T DENZEL TYRESE
COMMODE.
>> IT'S A MISTAKE THAT CAN
HAPPEN TO ANYBODY.
LIKE BRUSHING YOUR TEETH WITH
PREPARATION H.
>> OR PUTTING ON FLOOR WAX
BECAUSE YOU WAS ASHY.
WHO AMONG US?
>> FACT.
BIG GORILLA IS A
MULTIBILLION-DOLLAR INDUSTRY,
AND WE DESERVE HALF.
>> OR DOUBLE.
HERE'S SOMEBODY ELSE.
>> MY NAME IS DARIUS.
I USED GORILLA GLUE UNDER MY
DOO-RAG SO IT WOULDN'T SLIP OFF
AT NIGHT WHEN I'M DOING MY GIRL.
NOW IMAGINE MY SURPRISE WHEN IT
WOULDN'T COME OFF AT ALL.
I MEAN, WHAT THE HECK?
I GOT TO SING LIKE A WEDDING IN
FOUR DAYS.
OH, WE COMING FOR YOU, GORILLA,
TELL THEM, BABY.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
WE COMING FOR YOU TOO, SHARPIE,
AND SILLY PUTTY.
LOOK WHAT YOUR PUTTY DID TO MY
BUTT.
I SIT ALL WEIRD.
>> OH, BUTT.
OH, BUTT.
>> LOOK, WE ARE NOT STUPID
PEOPLE!
WE UNDERSTAND WHAT WE ARE UP
AGAINST.
>> AND WE KNOW IT'S GOING TO BE
HARD TAKING A GORILLA TO COURT
AND SUING HIM OVER HIS GLUE.
>> WHAT IF HE GET MAD ASK START
TEARING UP THE COURTROOM?
>> THAT'S A RISK WE ARE WILLING
TO TAKE.
THIS GORILLA IS PROBLEMATIC AND
NEEDS TO ANSWER FOR HIS
SO-CALLED BEAUTY GLUE.
>> MY NAME IS TASHA, AND LET'S
JUST SAY I TRIED TO GET MYSELF
AN INFINITY STONE, AND NOW IT'S
STUCK ON ME PERMANENT OR
WHATEVER.
AND I'M NOT GOING TO SAY IT
DON'T LOOK TIGHT.
BUT IT BURNS, Y'ALL.
DAMN YOU, GORILLAS!
>> FACT.
GORILLAS ARE NOTORIOUS FOR
THROWING THEY OWN DOO-DOO AT
FOLKS.
EVEN AT LITTLE CHILDRENS.
>> SO IT IS NOT HARD TO BELIEVE
THEY WOULD ALSO TRICK US INTO
USING THEIR GLUE AS BEAUTY
PRODUCTS.
>> OPEN-AND-SHUT CASE, IF YOU
ASK ME.
>> SO IF THIS HAS HAPPENED TO
YOU LIKE IT'S HAPPENED TO OUR
FAMILY --
>> CALL US TODAY.
WE KNOW WE CAN'T BE THE ONLY
FAMILY.
>> DON'T BE SILENCED BY BIG
GORILLA.
>> SON, GET YOUR HANDS OUT YOUR
PANTS, WE DOING A COMMERCIAL.
>> I CAN'T, IT'S GORILLA GLUE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> OH, NOT AGAIN.
>> LOOK.
WE ARE NOT STUPID PEOPLE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
SO CALL US AT 1-800-GLUE.
WE COMING FOR YOU, GORILLA.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]